[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen so salis welt
vor kurzem gab es schon eine leckere
toffifee trotte die auch einige von euch
schon nach gemacht und mich auf dem foto
verlinkt haben heute gibt's noch ein
zweites rezept von mir
und zwar habe ich mir überlegt mache ich
hoffe für cupcake muffins kleine
törtchen und dann kam mir die idee wir
machen kleine törtchen aus muffins und
die sehen richtig cool aus vor allem da
oben mit dem schokoladen gitter hat
schon als geniales oder was sagst du
geschlossen
das ist mal was anderes und einfach was
anderes als ein cupcake durch den süßen
eyecatcher auf jeder party auf jeden
fall
man kann sie auch als mini muffin machen
oder haben so wirklich militär tieren
also da könnte dann selber entscheiden
wie ihr das machen möchte
momentan gibt es ja eine
deutschlandweite aktion die heißt
deutschland pakt mit toffifee und die
aktions verpackung erkennt ihr auch weil
da vorne das logo von mir drauf ist in
jeder topf verpackung gibt es einen
aktionscode und hier unten drin ist der
code den kann man dann unter www.tk.de
einlösen und umwandeln in einem
gutscheincode für meinen onlineshop aber
außer diesem gutschein gibt es auch ein
richtig großes gewinnspiel und dieses
gewinnspiel läuft noch bis april
nächstes jahr und da gibt es ganz ganz
tolle gewinnt preise die ich euch am
ende des videos vorstellen
aber jetzt starten jetzt erst einmal mit
meinem video und mit diesem rezept wo
ich zeige euch mal die teig zu haben für
den teig verwende ich 150 gramm zucker
eine prise salz 150 gramm mehl etwas
backpulver 100 gramm gemahlene
haselnüsse zwei eier 150 gramm
sonnenblumenöl 100 gramm butter milch
den abriss einer zitrone und etwas man
den extrakt für den martinstag braucht
ihr gar keine küchenmaschine sondern
könnte den teig komplett mit einem back
löffel verrühren
also ich mache das immer gerne so wie
früher erst die trockenen zutaten und
dann die flüssigen
mehl backpulver und natron dann salz und
zucker dazu die haselnüsse mit rein
da könnte auch gern schneebesen nehmen
verbindet sich alles gut
[Musik]
und dann kommen jetzt hier die eier mit
rein das sonnenblumenöl und die
buttermilch
[Musik]
und natürlich man den extrakt und ein
bisschen zitronenschale update für die
frische
[Musik]
und jetzt alle zutaten gut verrühren
und jetzt kann ich schon die macht in
form neben und einfetten
da nehme ich jetzt auch keine papier
förmchen und bei dem rezept ist recht
ganz am anfang daran denken den ofen
vorzuhalten wenn der teig ist
superschnell gemacht jetzt bin ich
einfach mit dem reis portionierer den
teig und für den in die förmchen rein
[Musik]
und dann können die maschinen in den
backofen
[Musik]
die muffins gebacken und ich habe es ihr
ausgelöst und hier auf dem abkühlen
gitter abkühlen lassen
jetzt kann ich die zimt creme herstellen
für die creme verwende ich 300 gramm
sahne 500 gramm mascarpone 80 gramm
puderzucker etwas an apart sind nämlich
zuerst die mascarpone die kommt in die
rührschüssel und ich bereue ich jetzt
einmal kurz geschmeidig
[Musik]
jetzt kommen wir langsam die sahne dazu
hier kommt jetzt noch der puderzucker
dazu das sind pulver und etwas salopp
hat und man kann die creme schon steif
geschlagen werden
[Musik]
die creme habe ich jetzt kurz umgefüllt
in einen spritzbeutel mit loch hülle und
jetzt kann ich die martin fall wären
dafür setze ich das messer mit sich an
und schneidet einfach den deckel und
damit der rubel hier verschwindet
schneide ich auch hier nochmal den
deckel vorsichtig
[Musik]
jetzt sind die muffins schön halbiert
und die reste verarbeite ich einfach zu
kick box oder ich erst einfach so zum
kaffee jetzt kommt die creme an die
reihe
und die habe ich hier in der lokhalle
dem spritzbeutel und spritzt hier einmal
ausmachen
ganz viele kleine top
und entweder findet ihr jetzt die mitte
auch aus mit der creme oder ihr macht da
noch was wichtiges rein so was wie
apfelkompott zum beispiel
[Musik]
jetzt kommt hier in die mitte noch
kleiner toffifee so als krank dann ist
es hier oben drauf und oben dann mit der
creme noch mal abschließen
[Musik]
die törtchen stehen hits im kühlschrank
und jetzt kommt das schokoladen gittern
die reihe für das schokoladen gitter
habe ich 150 gramm türe bereits fein
gehackt und zwei drittel davon über dem
warmen wasserbad erhitzt jetzt ist die
kuvertüre geschmolzen und mit dem
restlichen drittel also mit den
restlichen 50 jetzt die kuvertüre wieder
herunter so dass sie einfach auf die
richtige temperatur kommt und beim
abkühlen keinen grauen schleier bekommen
[Musik]
und jetzt finde ich die kuvertüre
einfach in einen gefrierbeutel 1
und wenn ihr den so wie ich auf dem glas
stimmt dann hat man beide hände kommen
[Musik]
jetzt einfach zu zwiebeln und eine
kleine spitze wegschneiden und dann
könnte ein fachbuch ein gitter drauf
spritzen
[Musik]
jetzt lege ich hier kurz und akku
kühlpads drunter ist das einfach dieser
torten rettet er nicht da unten drunter
haben ein bisschen kühl wird und die
schokolade schneller anziehen wenn ihr
das nicht habt können das auch ganz
kurze im kühlschrank stellen aber die
kuvertüre wird auch wirklich bei
raumtemperatur super fenster in sehr gut
temperiert ist
[Musik]
jetzt nehme ich einfach einen ausstecher
einen runden und da ist etwa so groß wie
das törtchen und natürlich das gitter
ausstechen
[Musik]
also da empfehle ich euch ein paar
kreise mehr auszustechen als gebraucht
denn es kann parieren doch zu brechen
[Musik]
und am ende legt ihr dann ganz
vorsichtig das schoko peter drauf und
dekoriert eure törtchen mit dem toffifee
und was sagst du morath die schüler
probieren ok dann konkurrieren
aber bevor man probiert sage ich euch
noch was es zu gewinnen gibt beim großen
gewinnspiel in jeder toffifee verpackung
gibt es einen aktionscode diesen
aktionscode kann man dann bis zum 14
2019 auf trophäe einlösen und dann
erfahrt ihr auch direktorin preis
gewonnen habt anschließend erhaltet ihr
automatisch einen gutscheincode für
meinen online shop und den könnt ihr
dort dann bis zum 30.09 einlösen
deswegen lohnt es sich auf jeden fall
mitzumachen zu gewinnen gibt's nämlich
fünf bosch war ist ein kühlschränke mit
wechselbarer front so wie ich ihn zu
hause schon stehen habe den kitsch made
küchenmaschinen in der limitierten farbe
petrol von rama.com zehnmal das bak
starterset von meinem shop 100 trophy
face mit back schürze und topfit war
kannte und tausendmal das toffifee
backbuch sehr viele tolle preise
ja ich möchte jetzt gerne städtchen ist
okay aus der hand oder max gabel und
marketing
der betrieb bei dem erfolgreichen ist
immer alles und hand essen kann kommt
bei den menschen immer wieder oder dann
auch ein solches aussagen ist
[Musik]
also ich würde es mit der garten und sag
mal eine frucht schicht drin
ich habe also richtig cool macht es
unmöglich in bitterfeld es knackt noch
mal hab ich gesagt wenn ihr wieder war
es ganz okay auch wenn war schmeckt ganz
toll und ihr dann habe ich ja noch
einmal in die mitte weil ich nämlich ein
problem mit meiner
falls ihr das rezept auch nach machen
möchtet dann findet ihr es auf meinem
blog sallys - blog de verlinkt mich auf
jeden fall und kostet auch das foto mit
diesem hersteller ja also viel spaß beim
nachbacken viel erfolg beim gewinnspiel
ich drücke euch allen ganz ganz ganz
fest die daumen und wir sehen uns wieder
beim nächsten mal nicht so frisch ich
habe schon immer mein leicht und ist
vielleicht hast du ja vorher die zähne
geputzt
morath ich habe noch nie jemanden
eleganz dieses örtchen essen sehen so
etwas sagen macht gewinnspiel mit
schweren jungs offenbau
[Musik]